la visita de James es hoy a Ucrania la
primera que realiza desde la invasión a
gran escala desde el pasado 24 de
febrero del año pasado tiene gran
significado para los ucranianos en un
momento en el que se espera que en las
próximas semanas se dio esa
contraofensiva en el que las tropas de
Ucrania buscan expulsar a las fuerzas
rusas no solamente de ser territorio que
han ocupado en los últimos meses sino
también el que ya tenían desde el 2014
incluido la isla de crimea él lo que
vino a decir aquí es apoyar a los
ucranianos y a discutir con el
presidente bolodominio celenzi con el
que se reunió hoy no solamente sobre una
reunión que habrá mañana en Rammstein
Alemania entre 40 países que apoyan
militarmente a Ucrania y cómo discutir y
tener más ayuda de estos países sino
también sobre la próxima cumbre de la
otan que se llevará a cabo en julio al
cual ha sido invitado Y esto es
importante porque se le es que dijo que
él aceptaba la invitación pero que
también estaban esperando que Ucrania
recibiera esa invitación para empezar
ese proceso a ser parte de la alianza
del Atlántico Norte
el secretario general de la otan dijo
que realmente no había ninguna Barrera
objetiva para tomar una decisión
política para invitar a que Ucrania
hiciera parte de esta alianza que tanto
en Ucrania como los países que hacen
parte especialmente la población estaban
de acuerdo sin embargo aquí la gran
pregunta es cuánto tiempo se demorará en
tomar esa decisión Que obviamente es
extremadamente importante para Ucrania
que sigue presionando en que se acelere
su ingreso